مدن منكوبه هذا هو الحال في بعض المناطق
بتركيا كما في سوريا ايضا هذه مدينه هاتاي
تحكي المشاهد الجويه الملتقطه قصه المدينه
المنكوبه حيث الدمار يغطي اجزاء كبيره
منها مع تجاوز عدد ضحايا الزلزال فيها الى
حد الان 800
وفيها ايضا ولكن في مدينه اسكندرون تظهر
هذه المشاهد الدمار الكبيره التي لحق باحد
مستشفيات المدينه مع استمرار المحاولات
لرفع الانقاض والوصول الى الضحايا
المشهد في سوريا لا يختلف كثيرا الدمار
يغطي مساحه واسعه لكن هذه الصور القادمه
من جنديرس في ريف حلب احيت الامل في
العثور على نجينا بعد نجاح المسعفين في
اخراج عدد من الاطفال من تحت الانقاض عقب
اكثر من اربع وعشرين ساعه من الزلزال
وفي ادلب بدل مشهد مؤثرا بدوره وهذه
الفتاه تحمي شقيقها وقد حاصرتهما انقاض
المباني من كل مكان
كانت هذه نماذج من اقوى المشاهد المسجله
اليوم اما في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
فتصلنا هذه الصور من كهرمان مراش بالجنوب
التركيه حيث تم انقاذ عائله كامله بعد
اكثر من اربعين ساعه من عمليات الانقاذ
للدفاع المدني
والى غازي عنتاب التي وصلت اليها فرق
وانقاذ دوليه ومعدات بحث للمساهمه في
عمليات الانقاذ ومساعده ضحايا الزلزال
وهذه الصور من ريف ادلب بالشمال السوريه
حيث يعاني افراد الدفاع المدني في المناطق
التي تضررت من الزلزال من قله الامكانات
والى ناحيه جنديرس في عفرين شمال غربي
سوريا حيث اقيم دفن جماعي للعائلات التي
قضت تحت الركام بسبب الزلزال
في مواضيع الحصاد
عدد قتل الزلزال في تركيا يقترب من سته
الاف وعدد الجرح يتجاوز 30 الفا
انقره تقول ان الزلزال ضرب مساحه تبلغ 110
كيلومترات اردوغان يعلن حاله طوارئ في عشر
محافظات تركيه تضررت بزلزال هو الاشد منذ
قرابه ربع قرن وتوقف امدادات الغاز
لمحافظات تركيا عده بعد تضرر خطوط
الانابيب
عدد قتل الزلزال في عموم سوريا يتجاوز
2000 وسقوط الاف الجرحى تضرر المعبر
المستخدم لنقد المساعده الى شمال غرب
سوريا ومخاوف بشان مصير العالقين تحت
الالقاب
الزلزال المدمر سباق مع الزمن والبرد
لانقاذ الناجين المحتملين في تركيا وسوريا
بدا وصول المساعدات الدوليه وفرق المسعفين
الى تركيا وانقر تقول ان اكثر من 70 دوله
عرضت المساعده
وسط تحضيرات من توقع الاسوا الصحه
العالميه تقول ان عدد المتضررين بالزلزال
في تركيا وسوريا قد يصل الى 23 مليونا
وتتعهد بارسال امدادات طارئه والمتحدث
باسم الامين العامل للامم المتحده يقول
للجزيره ان المعابر بين جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا تواجه صعوبات تعيق ايصال المساعدات
[موسيقى]
في احدث المعلومات اعلن وزير الصحه
التركيه فخر الدين قوجه ارتفاع حصيله
ضحايا الزلزال الى ما يزيد عن 5000 واربع
مئه في حين بلغ عدد المصابين نحو 32 الفا
ولفت وزير الصحه التركيه لان عدد من تم
انقاذه من تحت الانقاذ في ولايتها طاي حتى
الان بلغ الفا و800 شخص مشيرا الى انهيار
الفين وسبعمائه وتسعه واربعين مبدا في
ولايتها تاي وحدها في حصيله اوليه كما
اعلن ان ما يقرب من عشره الاف شخص باتوا
في الخدمه على ارض الميدان ثلثهم من افراد
البحث والانقاذ
قال وزير الدفاع التركي خلصي اكر ان بلاده
تواجه كارثه كبيره وستتغلب عليها بالتكاتف
والمساعي المكثفه واشار الوزير التركي الى
انشاء جسر جوي الى المناطق المنكوبه
وارسال نحو
7000500 عنصر من قوات الجيش التركي الذين
باتوا على ارض الميدان ويشاركون في عمليات
البحث والانقاذ كما اشار اكر الى ان
القوات الجويه اجرت نحو 2003 طلعه جويه
للمشاركه في عمليه الانقاذ واخلاء
المصابين
مع تكشف حجم الكارثه التي ضربت تركيا
وسوريا تعالت اصوات المنظمات الانسانيه
المحليه والدوليه في الشمال السوري محذره
من نقص الامكانيات وشح الاليات اللازمه
لعمليه الانقاذ في ظل تعثر وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه بما فيها الادويه في مناطق
منكوبه اصلا تقرير ماجد عبد الهادي
بعد روح يارب يارب موت بالزلازل المدمره
يتلو موتا بالعواصف الثلجيه بعد موت
بالاسلحه الفتاكه والسوريون كالمعتاد في
صداره قوافل الضحايا يستغيثون دون كبير
امال بامكانيه نجدتهم او تخليصهم من هذه
السلسله الرهيبه في عالم طالما تهمه بانه
تصرف على مدى اثنتي عشره سنه داميه كانه
اعتاد رؤيتهم يذبحون
هم قالوا في وقت مبكر من العقد الماضي
قولتهم الجماعيه الشهيره ملنا غيرك يا
الله كنايه عن يقينهم بان حسابات المصالح
على المستوى الدولي كما الاقليمي اقتضت
تركهم لمصيرهم دونما اي محاولات جاده
لانقاذهم وما كان احد يتوقع حينئذ ان
تكتمل اشاحه البشريه بصرها عن نكبتهم
بوقوع كوارث طبيعيه
تقتل الوفا ناجين الذين سبق لهم ان
استطاعوا الفرار من كوارث اسوا كانت اسفرت
عن مقتل مئات الالوف منهم صحيح انهم الان
ليسوا وحدهم وان ملايين الاتراك معهم في
مهب العاصفه الزلداديه الجديده لكن
الساعات طويله القاسيه التي مرت منذ زلزله
الارض زلزالها على جانبي الحدود بين
البلدين المنكوبين ظلت وما زالت تؤكد
تباعا على كون هؤلاء
توريدها لمناطقهم ومن اي المعابر تمر وكيف
هنا وما زال يقال ان نوع وحجم الماساه
يقتضيان النائيه عن تسيسها ويستدعيان حصر
الاهتمام بجانبها الانساني قيل ايضا ان
هذا وقت التمعن في الكارثه او التامل في
ذواتنا بدلا من التنقيب في خلفيات الحدث
او ابعاده وتلك اقوال ربما تخفف او تعزز
وقع الالم في نفوس من يراقبون المشهد على
شاشات التلفزه كل حسب وجهات نظره غير انها
لن تغير الكثير في مشاعر ام تبحث بين
الركام عن ابنها وهي تدرك ان الاليات
والمعدات اللازمه لانقاضه او انتشال جثته
قد تعذر وصولها لاسباب سياسيه او نتيجه
عوامل ترتبط بجشع صناع الماسي وشروطهم بان
يكونوا هم الاوصياء على المعونات المرسله
الى الضحايا
بتاسيس الكلام عن الزلزال اذا او من دونه
يمر الوقت الذي طالما كان من دم وصار
اليوم من هواء او من اوكسجين تبتعد لحظه
وقوع الزلزال في الزمن فتضيق مع ابتعادها
انفاس الاحياء المطبورين تحت الركام او
تتحلل جثث الميتين منهم لتتحلل في اللحظات
نفسها ايضا ارواح الواقفين فوق الركام وان
ظلت السونهم تلهج بالنشيد القديم ملنا
غيرك يا الله
هذا وتسرعت جهود فرق الاغاثه لواء
المتضررين من الزلزال في تركيا لاسيما في
المناطق الاكثر تاثرا مع توقعات بانخفاض
اضافي في درجات الحراره ابتداء من
الاربعاء ولتسريع ايصال المساعدات حضرت
السلطات التركيه دخول السيارات الخاصه
داخل المدن للتخفيف من حده الازدحام سلام
خضر عاينت الاوضاع واعدت تقريرها التالي
يتركون منازلهم حاملين ما تيسر من متاع
ويشدون الرحال مرغمين نحو وجهه اكثر امنا
تنهكهم المسافات الطويله وتان ذاكرتهم تحت
وطاه مشاهد الدمار وهولي معانوه خلال
الزلزال وما تبعه من تداعيات منهم من فقد
قريبا وجلهم اضطر لترك مساكنهم بعد رحيل
السكينه عنها
مركز المدينه دمر بالكامل وهناك عالقون
تحت الانقاض حتى الان نشعر باننا لوحدنا
الناس في حاله يرثى لها الوضع في المدينه
سيء للغايه نتوجه الان الى انطاليا
سيل من السيارات على طريق بات ممرا للنفاذ
من المحافظات الاكثر تضررا ليسوا وحدهم
هنا شاحنات اغاثه تسابق الزمن لايصال
مساعدات للناجين والمنكوبين
ولتسهيل وصول المساعدات منعت السلطات
التركيه تجول السيارات الخاصه داخل المدن
فالاولويه لانقاذ المنكوبين اثناء تجولنا
على طريق المدن المنكوبه بفعل الزلزال هنا
في تركيا وصلنا الى مركز الايواء هذا في
مدينه كهرمان مراش التي تعتبر مركز
الزلزال الاعنف الذي حدث قبل يومين
والاكثر تاثرا مركز الايواء هذا بدات
منظمه افاد باقامته وهو مخصص لاواء
العائلات التي فقدت حقيقه كل شيء
سلام خضر الجزيره كهرمان مرعش
تحول الى شبكه مراسلينا من كهرمان مراش في
جنوب تركيا مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد العظيم
محمد من غازي عنتاب منتصر ابو نبوت من
جنديرس في عفرين بريف حلب عمرو حلبي ومن
ريف ادلب صهيب الخلف ابدا معك عبد العظيم
قربنا اكثر من الظروف المناخيه
والاغاثيه لعمليه الانقاذ
نعم جلال الظروف صعبه جدا حقيقه على الارض
الظروف المناخيه البرد قارس جدا نحن خمس
درجات تحت الصفر في هذه المنطقه في مدينه
كرمان مرش
المنكوبه التي معظم سكانها معظم سكانها في
خارج منازلهم في الطرقات بين من يسكن
السياره ومن يسكن الارصفه
والحدائق القريبه نحن الان في منطقه
محاوله انقاذ لبعض الناجين في هذا المكان
الذي تشاهدون خلفي هذا المكان
اخرجت طفله قبل تقريبا
ساعتين من هذا المكان وبجوارها يوجد سمع
اصوات يقول المسعفون كما اخبرونا ثلاث
الان يشيرون لنا بالصمت
يحاولون الحديث مع
الذين تحت الانقاض هناك ثلاثه اشخاص
تاكدوا من ان شخصا
تحدثوا معه تاكدوا وهو والد الطفله التي
خرجت وهناك شخصين اخرين من عائله اخرى
ايضا يعتقدون انهم يستطيعون الوصول اليهم
في هذه المنطقه جاءت
فرق انقاذ جديده الى هذا المكان في محاوله
منها للمساعده في اخراج بعض العالقين تحت
الانقاض وهذه البنايات اخرج منها
العديد من
العالقين احياء من تحت هذه الانقاذ ولذلك
لا يزال
الذين
لديهم عالقين في هذه البنايات لا يزالون
يتواجدون في هذه المنطقه وفي
على الارصفه وعلى الطرقات في
[موسيقى]
يلتحقون
البطانيات
ويشعلون النيران في محاوله لي التدفق
للتدفق
للاحتماء من هذا البرد القارص جدا
ويرفضون مغادره هذه الاماكن على امل ان
يصلوا الى ذويهم الذين لا يزالون تحت
الانقاض انا شاهدت عائله عندما وصلت الى
هذا المكان عائله تقيم بجانب مبنى مدمر
لديها طفلين احدهم 11 سنه والاخر ثلاث
سنوات لا يزالون تحت الانقاض يريدون
اخراجهم باي شكل ولا يزال لديهم امل
باخراجهم من هذا المكان
العديد من العوائل هي من تفتش بين الانقاض
وتخبر احيانا يخبرون الفرق الانقاذ بوجود
اصوات
احيانا يصلون الى هؤلاء الذين تحت الانقاض
واحيانا
تكون عمليه الاخبار غير دقيقه
ويتحولون من مكان الى اخر لكن الجميع في
حاله استنفار كامله على امل كما قالوا
النائب الرئيس التركي ان هناك 48 ساعه
حاسمه في الوصول الى الناجين وسنبذل جهدنا
للوصول الى
تحت الانقاض سنعود اليك عبد العظيم محمد
في كهرمان مراش وهي مركز الزلزال في تركيا
تتحول الى داخل سوريا في جنديرس عمر حلبي
ربما جنديرس كانت هي الاكثر تضررا على
الجانب السوري اطلعنا ايضا على ابرز
المعوقات
امام عمليات الانقاذ
في هذا المبنى الان كما قلت لك هناك كان
الام وكذلك بنتان والان عمليات البحث
جاريه حتى يتم استخراج الاب والرجل من تحت
الانقاض في تلك المجموعه الاولى الان
يحاولون ان يستخرجوا الرجل من تحت الانقاض
اخبرنا قبل الهواء هذا الرجل بانه كان
الرجل كان يحتضن البنت وتم استخراج البنت
من بين يديه
ولكنها تفارقت الحياه والرجل الان يحاولون
استخراجه في المجموعه الاخرى تلك تماما
هنالك عائله اخرى ايضا فقد افراد عائله
فقد او فقدت العائله حياتها وهم تحت
الانقاض ويحاولون ويحاول الدفاع المدني
الان وفرق الانقاذ ان يقوموا باستخراج
الجثث هناك ايضا مجموعه اخرى من الاهالي
ومن عمال الانقاذ يحاولون
في مواقع اخرى
يحاولون ايضا ان يبحثوا عن مفقودين تحت
الانقاذ حسب ما اخبرنا الاهالي فان هنالك
اربعه عوائل الان هناك اربعه عوائل الان
في هذا تحت هذا الركام
لا يعلمون ان كان منهم احياء كان هناك
شكوك بان يكون تحت هذا الركام بعض من
الاحياء لكن على ما يبدو للاسف حتى الان
تم استخراج نحو 30 جثه من تحت هذا الركام
وكلهم فقدوا وكل الاشخاص الذين تم
استخراجه جثثهم من تحت الركام فرقوا
الحياه هنالك محاولات مستمره للبحث عن
الناجين وهناك محاولات ايضا لعمليه انتشال
باقي الجثث لانه كما قلت لكم هنالك نحو
اربعه عائلات تقدر اعدادهم بنحو ما بين 10
الى نحو 15 شخصا العمل متواصل على مدار
الساعه انت تشاهد الان فرق وعناصر من
الدفاع المدني
نحن كنا في الحقيقه نحاول نتقدم اكثر لكن
ترى الصخور تمنعنا من التقدم الى المكان
وايضا حتى لا نعيق على هؤلاء عملهم لانه
الاولويه لهؤلاء طبعا في عملهم العمليات
مستمره على مدار الساعه جميع فرق الدفاع
المدني في الحقيقه هنا في جنديرس استنفرد
عناصرها ومعداتها الى هذا المكان لان هذا
المكان الدمار فيه ضخم وضخم جدا اكثر
الاحياء تضررا في الاحياء جنديرس انا الان
اقف هنا هذا بناء كان من سته طابق كله
مدمر على يميني المصور ممكن لو سمحت على
هذا البناء هذا البناء ايضا هو لم يسقط
على الارض الحمد لله طبعا لكن انظر هو
الان غير صالح للسكنه هناك تماما خلفك عبد
الرحمن خلفك هذا البناء الان خلف المصور
تماما لم يسقط ولكنه ايضا لم يعد صالح
للسكنه لانه ايضا
تضرر بفعل الزلزال وهكذا كل الابنيه
الموجوده في هذا الشارع جلال هي ما بين
مدمره اما بشكل كامل مثل هذا المبنى او
بشكل جزئي مثل المباني التي رايتها او هي
اصابتها شقوق وتصدعات كبيره ولم يعد
الاهالي قادرين على السكنه فيها لذلك الان
نحن نشاهد الاهالي منقسمين ما بين من
يساعد في عمليات
الانقاذ وبين من يفترسون الطرقات راينا
قبل قليل خلف هذه الاليات من هم
قد اشعلوا النار ويقومون بالتدفئه هناك
اناس اخرون في سياراتهم كما تفضلت الزملاء
قبل قليل في السيارات واخرون في المساجد
في الصالات
الظلام دامس في المدينه لاتصالات مقطوعه
يعني علينا كثيرا حتى تمكنا من ايجاد
وسيله بث حتى ننقل هذه الصور بشكل حي على
الهواء من هذه الناحيه من ناحيه جنديرس هي
اكثر المناطق في الحقيقه تضررا في ريف حلب
الشمالي ومن اكثر المناطق التي دمرت فيها
مباني حوالي 290 مبنى المجلس المحلي يقول
نحو الف بناء لم يعد صالحا للسكن في
جنديرس وهي من اكثر المناطق تضررا اذا في
ريف حلب جلال ماذا عن ريف ادلب حيث صهيب
الخلف صهيب طبعا نداءات استغاثه
ومطالب ايضا بحضور معدات لازمه لاستكمال
عمليات الانقاذ كيف تصف الوضع
نعم جلال ما تزال فرق الدفاع المدني
والمتطوعين الاخرين يعملون وبدون توقف على
الوصول الى العالقين تحت الانقاض والى
الضحايا والى الناجين المحتملين لانه وفي
هذا الموقع حيث انا الان بسنيا في قرب
الحدود السوريه التركيه اخرج عند المساء
اخرجت فرق الدفاع المدني سته اشخاص على
قيد الحياه منهم خمسه اشخاص عائله واحده
اب وام وثلاثه اطفال وايضا شخص اخر اخرج
بعد ذلك الامر الذي اعطى الامل للمنقذين
ليواصلوا عمليات الانقاذ الان وفي هذه
اللحظات خمس جرافات تعمل على رفع الانقاض
هذه المبني المجمع السكني كان محاط
المباني كانت محاطه بمحال تجاريه وبالتالي
فان على الجرافات ان تتقدم باتجاه
المبنى لتزيل المحال التجاريه ومن ثم بعد
ذلك تصل الى حواف بيوت وتبدا بفتح منافذ
من خلال الطبقات البيتونيه التي تكدست فوق
بعضها ومن ثم بعد ذلك ينتظر او يسمع يحاول
المنقذون ان يسمعوا اي صوت من داخل
المباني وبعد ذلك
يتدخلون بشكل مباشر ويدخلون الى داخل
المباني من خلال رفع الطبقات البيتونيه
بدعامات خشبيه
والمتطوعين المدنيين ايضا يساهمون بشكل
فعال وفق ما تحدث الينا
متطوعون الدفاع المدني الذين قالوا طلبوا
من المدنيين بان يخففوا من تواجده من
تواجدهم في هذا الموقع وان يذهبوا الى
موقع اخر لان عدد المتطوعين المدنيين اصبح
يعرقل العمل هنا المتطوعون المدنيون
يتسلمون مناطق معينه يقومون بتدمير
الطبقات البيتونيه العليا
ما يشكون باي وجود احد او يسمعون اي صوت
فانهم يصرخون على متطوعي الدفاع المدني
يتدخلوا بدورهم ويبداوا بعمليات الانقاذ
الدقيقه
والحساسه والتي تحتاج الى خبره عاليه هذا
هذه الطريقه
اتت اكلها حقيقه بدليل قدره المتطوعين
الدفاع المدني على اخراج اناس احياء كما
اسلفت منتصر ابو نبوت في غازي عنتاب لا
اعتقد بان المشهد يختلف لديك
صحيح المشهد لا يختلف لكن دعني في البدايه
اتحدث عن الطائرات التي لم تتوقف منذ نحو
نصفي ساعه في سماء مدينه غازي عنتاب هي
طائرات شحن
على ما يبدو هذه ضمن جهود الجسر الجوي
الذي يسعى من خلاله الذي تسعى من خلال
الحكومه التركيه الى التخفيف ان الوصف هذه
الكارثه نحن الان في احد الحدائق الكبيره
في مدينه غازي عنتاب في هذه الحديقه هناك
عشرات السيارات التي فيها عائلات لا
يريدون العوده الى منازلهم ولديهم سيارات
فجاءوا الى هذه الحديقه نساعد هنا هذه بعض
السيارات وايضا في الجانب الاخر هنا في
الجهه الاخرى او حركنا الكاميرا الى هذا
الجانب سنجد ايضا عدد كبير من هذه
السيارات كل سياره من هذه توجد فيها عائله
تحاول ان تبقى في مكان بعيد كما نشاهد هنا
لا يوجد مباني في محيط هذه السيارات فهم
لا يريدون ان يكونوا بالقرب من مباني
كبيره لذلك ياتون الى مناطق واسعه وتكون
هذه المناطق اكثر امنا لهم في حال تجدد
هذا الزلزال او جاءت
ارتداداته ارتدادات هذا الى
مدينه غازي عنتاب او حتى في المناطق
المجاوره لان اغلب
الاهالي والسكان في المناطق المجاوره
تتعرضت للضربات في هذا الزلزال يستخدمون
نفس هذه الطريقه في محاوله للهرب من البلد
نحن الان يعني في فصل الشتاء ودرجات حاره
متدنيه خصوصا ان مدينه غازي عنتاب كان
فيها يعني
تساقط الثلوج شكرا وقوع هذا الزلزال بنحو
يعني يومين وكانت هناك بعض
وكانت هناك بعض الاحياء والشوارع قد اغلقت
هذه الثلوج ثم جاء هذا الزلزال والذي
ترافق ايضا
تساقط وعاصفه ثلجيه وزادت من وطته معاناه
الاهالي الذين الان يفترشون فعليا العراء
او منهم يجلس في السيارات منهم من يقوم
باشعال النيران في
الحدائق وفي الساحات العامه بحثا عن الدفا
للتخفيف من معاناه البرد التي يعيشونها
شكرا لشبكه مراسلين سنعود لكم بطبيعه
الحال منتصر او نبوت في غازي عنتاب عمر
حلبي في جنديرس عبد العظيم محمد في كهرمان
مراش وصهيب الخلف في ريف ادلب ومن ريف
ادلب الينا السيد احمد يازجي عضو مجلس
اداره الدفاع المدني السوري سيد احمد ما
حجم الضرر في ريف ادلب جراء زلزال
حجر ضرر كبير دائما ما نقوم بتوسيق هذا
الضرر عن طريق الفرق المتواجده حاليا على
الارض التي تعمل على انتشال العالقين وسط
احصائيه الان الى 1020 قتيل بالاضافه الى
اكثر من 2600 جريح الاعصائيين الان
المعروفه انها تتغير بالدقائق
هذه الاحصائيين
جدا وصفنا حوالي 310 مباني دمرت بشكل كامل
بالاضافه الى
اكثر من 600 دمر بشكل جزئي بالاضافه لالاف
المباني التي تصدعت حجم الدمار كبير
الكارثه كبيره الفرق ما زالت تعمل الى
الان الحمد لله هلا الخبر مباشر عمليه
انقاذ
الطفل على قيد الحياه عند عمل استمر من
امبارح الى الان
الى الى هذه الساعه يقومها بعمليات طيب
لديكم فكره تقريبيه عن عدد المفقودين حتى
الان في ريف ادلب
عدد المفقودين
متغير
للامانه للاسف انه رقم متغير الارقام
دائما ما هي تتغير المباني في بعض المناطق
على سبيل المثال منطقه بثانيه هي المناطق
التي
تهدمت هي مباني
يقسم فيها نازحين الارقام بالنسبه لاهل
المبنى لا يعلمون ما هو العدد بالكامل لكل
مبنى دائما
الارقام المتغيره ولكن على حسب الاعداد
الاوليه يوجد اكثر من 700
700 شخص متواجد تحت الانقاذ كرقم مبدئي
وليس وهو ايضا متغير في احد المباني
السكنيه كان على
مسعود عيان ان هذا المبنى يسكن فيه 13
شخصا ولكن خلال عمليات البحث تواجد في هذا
المبنى اكثر
هذه الارقام هي متغيره الدقائق لذلك ان
نعطي احصائيه عن عدد المفقودين الى يعني
على اقل تقدير هناك 700 شخص في ريف ادلب
تحت الانقاض حتى الساعه طيب كيف تصفون
ظروف عمليات الانقاذ الامكانيات التي التي
لديكم ايضا
هلا عمليات وانقاذ اصبحت جميع يعلم ان
الدفاع المدني يعمل بالامكانيات المتواجده
لدينا
مقارنه بهذه الكارثه التي امتدت على
جغرافيا واسعه بشان كامل شمال سوريا
نقص بالمعدات نقص بالاليات الثقيله
كان هناك نداءات لعد الجهات المحليه وجهات
مدنيه للاستمرار
باستمرار بالاليات نعمل الان مع عده
شركاء موجودين على الارض وحتى جهات مدنيه
بالاليات الثقيله
الظروف العمل صعبه بهذا النقص ونحن نسابق
الزمن للامانه للاشخاص
في اشخاص على قيد الحياه
التنقلات هذه الاليات لن تكون بالامر
السهل فهناك دائما ما يكون الي
دائما ما هي متحركه من مكان الى اخر هذه
الامكانيات اللي بين ايدينا نحن عم نحاول
نستغلها في هذا المكان لما بنحاول ننتهي
منه وما بكون في عالقين وتم انتشار
المصابين والضحايا
لالين
فالعمل ليس بالسهل ضمن الامكانيات
المتوفره بين ايدينا بالاضافه كان الجو
اليوم كان الجو مشمس ولكن بالامس كانت
الجو الطقس صعب جدا امطار غزيره ساعات
الليل كان الهواء
بالاضافه الى درجات الحراره التي كانت دون
الصفر فمن ضمنها الاجواء بالاضافه اللي
الهزات الارتداديه التي رافقت هذا كانت
ايام ايضا مسبب خوف على الطواقم التي تعمل
بالاضافه ايضا للمدنيين متواجدين الان
الذين يتواجدون في العراق اقول في العراق
لانه
لحد هذه اللحظه يوجد عوائل موجوده هي في
الشوارع ما في امان انه ترجع على على
المباني
منها
الوضع صعب وكارثه شكرا لك سيد احمد عضو
مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني السوري في ريف
ادلب
وحيدا كدابه يواجه محنته يصارع شمال
السوري اثار التابعات المدمره لزلزال عابر
للحدود
ويحذر الصليب الاحمر الدولي من ان الوضع
الانساني هنا مروع اما السوريون فيشاهدون
في عجز ما تواجهه جهود الاغاثه وايصال
المساعدات من تحديات تفاقم الماسه
كثير من الوعود من الدول والمنظمات
الانسانيه وقليل من الفعل فاين مكمل الخلل
قيل ان الامر يعود في جانب منه الى عوائق
لوجستيه وقبل ذلك الى الاضرار الفادحه
التي احدثها الزلزال المدمر في تركيا تلك
التي شملت شبكه الطرق المعتمده عاده في
الاعمال الانسانيه لم يسلم من الضرر معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي في ادلب المنفذ الوحيد
المتاح لنقل المساعدات الى المناطق
المنكوبه في الداخل السوري لذلك اوقفت
الامم المتحده مؤقتا كما قالت تدفق
مساعداتها العاجله القادمه من تركيا عبر
المعبر الذي تؤطره اليه معتمده بقرار دولي
وهنا تعلو دعوات لادخال المساعدات الدوليه
عن طريق معابر بديله كمعبر باب السلامه في
ريف حلب ومعابر الراعي وجرابلس فاعاده
تفعيل بقيه المعابر مع تركيا سيتيح
استفاده اوسع من شبكه الطرق التي تصلها
بالشمال السوري
توزع المنكوبين من ابناء سوريا بين مناطق
يسيطر عليها مسلحها المعارضه واخرى واقعه
تحت سيطره النظام الخاضع للعقوبات لا يسهل
المهمه فهذه بلاد ما تزال منطقه غير واضحه
من وجهه نظر قانونيه ودبلوماسيه اما
انسانيا فيتسارع السباق هنا مع الزمن في
غياب المعدات اللازمه تتواصل الجهود
لانتشال ناجين محتملين عالقين تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
وفي الوقت عينه تزداد حاجه الناجين
والمشردين من منازلهم بفعل الزلزال الى ما
يبقيهم على قيد الحياه
تداول نشطون على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
فيديو لفتن سوري عالق بين انقاذ منزله
المدمر نتيجه الزلزال وعبر الفتى عن مشاعر
الخوف التي تنتابه هو وافراد اسرته
وجيرانه العلقين تحت ركام المنزل المدمر
ويظهر في الفيديو اصوات اطفال بجوارها
عالقين تحت الانقاض قبل ان تباغتهم هز
ارضيه اخرى ولم يعرف مصيرهم بعد هذه
اللقطات
طبعا هذا الفيديو ما بعرف اذا بدي اموت
الله عايش شايفين
الحمد لله كل شيء اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
واشهد ان محمد رسول الله
هذا الفيديو نزل
انا الحمد لله طلعت عايش
ة
الشعور انه تكون تحت الانقاذ
انتم شايفين حاليا
تحت الانقاص والناس يعني
اكثر من يمكن عيلتين ثلاثه اربع عيال نحن
وعائلتك
والجيران تبعتنا
الله يعين هزه ارضيه
ما بعرف شو
طبعا الاف مثل هذا الفتى تحت الانقاذ في
تركيا وسوريا
في جنوب تركيا سعيد عز الدين منسق
العلاقات الخارجيه في هيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه التركيه سيد عز الدين اريد ان
اسالك اولا عن حجم الضرر في معبر باب
الهوى هل بحسب تقييمكم هل هو قابل للصيانه
قريبا
طبعا حاليا الوضع الهواء في طول الصيانه
طبعا الزلزال اسهر بشكل عام على الجنوب
الولاده التركيه كامله
بالنسبه التحتيه الواصله منها طاي الى
المنفذ الوحيد
حاليا متاثر بشكل كبير بسبب
الزلزال وارتدادات الطبقات طبعا حاليا
الفرق الموجوده من قبل هجوم التركيه
والعامل المعروفه مباشره هذا الامر طيب
كيف تصفون اعمال الاغاثه حتى الان في
المناطق التي اطلعت عليها
يعني طبعا مع ساعات الفجر الاولى من
الزلزال من الشهر الجاري
كان الامر كتير شديد في الولايات الجنوبيه
وخاصه
يعني اكثر من
مئات المباني التي دمرت
والافرضت فرقنا الموجوده من فرق البحث
والانقاذ في مدينه
ساعات الفجر الاولى على انقاذ واجلال
الضحايا ومساعده ودعم الفرق
الانقاذ التعبئه الحكومه التركيه واجزاء
الضحايا واضافه الى عمل متطوعين الى تامين
المواد الاساسيه والاحتياجات العاجله من
بطانيات ووجبات ساخنه
وبالاضافه الى انشاء مخيماتي وبالناس التي
ماتت في العراق ومن المعلوم الساعات
الزلزال التي حصلت كانت في ساعات الفجر
بالاضافه الى تدم درجات الحراره سله على
الناس بشكل عام ومن الشريحه التي يضررت
اكثر من الاطفال والشيوخ
ما الاولويه بالنسبه لكم الان في هذه
المرحله كهيئه اغاثيه
طبعا حاليا الاولويتنا هي
انك
للحكومه والاضافه الى يوجد الان الاف
العوائل التي حاليا في العراق حينما وممكن
اغلب العوائل حاليا
بالسيارات من المعروف الهزات التي
اجبرت العوائل الى ترك منازلها حاليا اننا
نتكلم
المباني باتت غير صالحه للسكن حاليا فقط
انطاكيا اكثر من 60 او 70% من المدينه
مدمر اضافه الى المشهد في وقت
والاحتياجات الاساسيه شكرا لك السيد سعيد
عز الدين منسق العلاقات الخارجيه في هيئه
الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه في هاتاي
تحديدا جنوب تركيا
استمر تدفق المساعدات الانسانيه والفرق
الطبيه وعناصر البحث والانقاذ من عدد من
الدول على مطار غازي عنتاب جنوبي تركيا
وصلت اليوم اربع طائرات قطريه في اطار جسر
جوي اقامته الدوحه لنقل المساعدات
الانسانيه وتجهيزات الكافيه لمستشفيين
ميدانيين بالاضافه الى مسعفين وفرق البحث
والانقاذ كما وصلت الى مطار غازي عنتاب
طائرات من دول اخرى للهدف ذاته يونس ايه
ياسين عين الاوضاع في المطار واعد تقديره
التالي
الطائره تحمل طريقا من يعني
المسعفين وفرق البحث والانقاذ البريطانيه
عملوا معهم ادويه حملوا معهم خلافا مدربه
للمساعده في عمليات البحث هذا الفريق
البريطاني الان ينتظر الانتهاء من اجراءات
ودخوله الى تركيا اليوم ايضا وصلت الى
تركيا والى مطار غازي عنتاب اربع طائرات
قطريه في اطار جسر جوي دشنته الحكومه
القطريه من اجل تقديم المساعدات لتركيا في
هذه الازمه التي تعيشها ويعني
بالاضافه الى هذه الاربع طائرات حملت 140
من عناصر الفرق الانقاذ والبحث مسعفين
واطباء والمستلزمات الكافيه لبناء
مستشفيين ميدانيين حتى الان لا نعرف لا
نعلم اين سوف يتم بنائها لكن التجهيزات
الضروريه لبناء الميدانيين قد وصلت وهذا
الفرق القطريه سوف تلتحق باداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه التي سوف تحدد ما هي
الاماكن التي توجد فيها حاجه لمثل هذه
هذا
المطر ليس يعني في حركيه نشيطه لايصال
المساعدات ووصول القوافل
والدعم الذي تقدمه عدد من الدول وسر
الطائره من اسرائيل وسط الطائره من ايران
طائره من تركمانستان هناك دول كثيره يتم
ايصال المساعدات عبر مطار غازي عنتاب
بالنظر الى انه المطار الذي لم يتضرر
كثيرا مقارنه مع مطارات اخرى في الجنوب
التركي لكن المطار ايضا هو ماوى وملجا
لعديد من سكان ولايه غازي عنتاب الذين
يعني شعروا بالقلق خلال اليومين الماضي
بعد كثره الزلازل والهزات الارتداديه
يعني على الاقل في هذه القاعه يتواجد
هؤلاء الذين يرون يعني يجدون فيها مكان
دافئ مكان يتم توفير فيه الغذاء وبالتالي
يعني اطفالي يجدون الامان او الحد الادنى
من الامان لكي يعني يهنائ بساعات قليله من
النوم مقارنه مع اخرين يتواجدون في شوارع
والساحات العموميه في مدينه غازي عنتاب
الذين يخشون حتى الان من العوده الى
منازلهم
يستمر وصول المساعدات الاغاثيه الى تركيا
وسوريا من نحو 70 دوله في العالم وفور
وصولها بدات طلائع فرق الانقاذ عملها في
سباق مع الزمن املا في العثور على ناجينا
تحت الانقاض
على تركيا وبشكل اقل سوريا تتدفق فرق
الاغاثه من مختلف انحاء العالم
تتعزز عمليات الانقاذ لكنها في اليوم
التالي للزلزال المدمر تواجه تحدي الوقت
والطقس في العثور على احياء تحت الركام
الهبه الدوليه لمساعده البلدين المنكوبين
ضمت عشرات البلدان على امتداد القارات
الخمس وبمشاركات متفاوته قوامها فرق انقاذ
واطقم طبيه ومعدات ومستشفيات ميدانيه
وغيرها من الامدادات الغذائيه والدوائيه
مؤازره للضحايا في هذه الفاجعه الانسانيه
الكبرى
وبينما يستمر اتباعا وصول فرق الانقاذ
والاسعاف بدات اولى طلائعها فورا عمليات
البحث والانقاذ لا سيما في المدن التركيه
المنكوبه وهي عمليات توشك على ان تدخل
مرحله حرجه فمع انقضاء كل ساعه بل كل
دقيقه تتضاءل فرص العثور على ناجين لا
سيما من الاطفال الذين رجحت منظمه الامم
المتحده للطفوله يونيسيف ان يكون الاف
منهم قد قضوا في هذا الزلزال اما منظمه
الصحه العالميه فتوقعت ان يصل عدد
المتضررين من الزلزال الى 23 مليون شخص
والوضع اكثر سوءا في المناطق السوريه خاصه
تلك الخارج عن سلطه النظام شمالا اذ تواجه
جهود الاغاثه عقبات اشد تعقيدا تبدا
بالعوائق اللوجستيه ممثله بانعدام
والموانئ واغلاق معظم المعابر الحدوديه
باستثناء معبر باب الهوى المكتظ فضلا عن
الاعتبارات السياسيه والقانونيه التي تحول
دون التنسيق مع دمشق الخاضعه لعقوبات
دوليه منذ سنوات
طلب علينا من جنافه
المتحدثه باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه
دكتوره تقديرات منظمه الصحه بان ارقام
الضحايا ستكون اعلى بثمان مرات هل لك ان
تطلعيننا على معطياتكم بهذا الشان
ما نعلمه ان 23 مليون شخص معرضون للخطر
نتيجه هذه الهزات الارضيه في البلدين وذلك
بسبب حجم الضرر والموجود ونعلم ان حوالي
خمسه ملايين شخص من هؤلاء اكثر ضعفا
وهشاشه
والواقع فعلا
12 مليون شخص في سوريا فعلا كانوا قبل هذا
بحاجه ماسه الى استجابه للرعايه انسانيه
وبالتالي هذا خليط او هذه كارثه فوق كارثه
اصابه هؤلاء الناس الذين يعانون من هذا
الاوقات العصيبه جدا ما الدوره التي يمكن
ان تلعبها منظمه الصحه العالميه في هذه
المرحله دكتوره
طبعا هو انقاذ حياه البشر ولكن طبعا هذه
اوقات صعبه فمن الصعب الوصول او الحصول
على المعدات الطبيه المناسبه ومساعد
المناسبه لكل ظرف علينا تاكد من وجود
الخبرات التي يحتاجها البلدان الذين طلبان
منا ان ناتي بهم بفرق والطوارئ الطبيه
وكما نقدم معدات وتجهيزات
وتجهيزات العمليات والمعالجه الصدمات في
سوريا ولدينا رحلتين مليئتين
وانتقلان منها دبي واحنا من اكثر من 160
من المواد الطبيه
والجراحيه
وبالتالي هناك عمل كبير ضروري لدعم
المنظومات الصحيه الموجوده في البلدين
لمساعده تربيه الاحتياجات الانيه وايضا
على المشاكل بعيده المستمره بسبب الضرر
الكثير الذي اصاب المستشفيات
والمشروع فيه نعلم بان التركيز الان على
اسعاف المصابين واخراج ايضا العلكي
العالقين عفوا من تحت الانقاض ولكن كما
نظمت الصحه هل تتخوفون من امراض جانبيه
ممكن ان تظهر مع كوارث مماثله
نعم فعلا نعم عادات كبيره من الناس الذين
يعيشون في صعوبه ضعف والصعبه جدا والدرجات
حراره بارده جدا تحت الصفر ولا يحصلون على
الماء النظيف وبتنظر لتوفير الماء النظيف
له لكل منه في تلك المناطق لانك فعلا خطر
انتشار الكوليرا فنحن كانت موجوده في شمال
شرق سوريا
واذا ما حصل ايضا في انظمه صرف تصريف
المياه فذلك قد يؤدي الى امراض كثيره مثل
الكوليرا واصابات المعويه ولكن مع التجمع
الناس مش كان كبيره قد يكون انتقال
للامراض واذا كان الناس يعانون الكثير من
النفسيه فهم في حاله حزن كعابه وشاهد
اشياء فظيعه والظروفهم فظيعه وهذا يؤثر
على
الجهاز المناعي في الاجسام مما يجعلهم
اكثر التعرضا لاخطار قد تكون اصاباتنا
امراض بسيطه لكنها تصبح كثيره جدا في مثل
هذه الظروف كيف ترون الاستجابات الدوليه
للمساعده سواء كان في تركيا او في سوريا
دكتوره
نحن شاهدنا ان هناك
رغبه كبيره جدا لتقديم المساعدات ونامل
ازداد ذلك
بالنسبه للبلدين هناك وضعين مختلفين
فتركيا فيها
نظام استجابه الكوارث ونظام صحي متقدمين
جدا وبالتالي الدعم الذي
يحتاجونه يعتمد على كيف يريدون الامور
ولكن الامر يختلف في شمال غربي سوريا حيث
هناك هناك نزاع مستمر هناك
وكان هناك ضرر كبير فعلا قبل الكارثه هذه
ومشاكل كثيره ثم يتعلق بالوصول الى ذلك
ولكن بالنسبه لنا في منظمه الصحه العالميه
نعلم هناك ومنذ زمن بعيد لدعم صحه الناس
هناك وبالتالي من المهم جدا ان كل الشركاء
وكل من لتقديم المساعده ان يفعل ذلك اينما
كان هناك بحاجه للمساعده شكرا لك الدكتور
مارجريت حارس المتحدث باسم منظمه الصحه
العالميه
تتكون الطبقه الخارجيه للارض المعروفه
باسم الغلاف الصخري من عدد من الصفائح
التكتونيه الكبيره او الحواف تتحرك لتكون
اما متباعده عن بعضها او مستضمه او منزلقه
عبر حدودها ما يجعل الزلازل مدمره وجود
تحركات عنيفه وقويه في الصفائح التكتونيه
وتتسبب هذه القوه في هزات ارضيه تبعتها
تختلف حسب اختلاف قوه التصادم ولان تركيا
تقع بين لوحين متصادمين هما لوح شمال
افريقيا ولوح منطقه اوراسيا فالزلازل تحدث
عاده عند تقابل هذين اللوحين وتحركيهما
ويسمى الاصطدام عمليه الاندساس على مر
الازمنه تشكلت احزمه زلزاليه ابرزها
واشهرها الحزم الناري ويمتد على طول
اربعين الف كيلو متر من التشيلي الى
المكسيك مرورا بالساحل الغربي للولايات
المتحده الى الاجزاء الجنوبيه من الاسكا
ثم يمتد ليشمل اليابان والفلبين وغينيا
الجديده
يشبه حدوه حصان ويسمى حزم النار لانه يضم
اكثر من 450 بركانا ويحدث فيه نحو 80% من
زلازل الارض الاعنف في العالم بينها زلزال
تشيلي الكبير عام 60 من القرن الماضي
الحزام الاخر هو الحزام الالبي ويقع في
منطقه تمتد لاكثر من 15 الف كيلو متر من
جاوا واوسو في اندونيسيا نحو المحيط
الاطلسي ويعبر جبال الهيمالايا وجبال
ايران والقوقاز والاناضول والبحر الابيض
المتوسط في هذا الحزام تقع نحو 17% من
اكبر الزلازل في العالم وشهد اكثر الزلازل
تدميرا مثل زلزال باكستان عام 2005 وزلزال
اندونيسيا المدمر عام 2004
من ابرز الدول المهدده بزلازل في هذا
الحزام كل من تركيا والهند وكازاخستان
ودول جنوب اوروبا المطله على البحر الابيض
المتوسط ودول الشرق الاوسط مثل سوريا
ولبنان ودول شمال افريقيا ومصر الحزام
الثالث هو حزام منتصف الاطلسي ويمثل منطقه
التقاء الصفائح القاريه ويحدث في عمق
المحيط وبعيدا عن الاماكن الحضريه مسؤول
عن ثلاثه في المئه فقط من الزلازل الكبيره
اذ ان اغلبها صغيره لكن ايسلندا كمثال
تعرضت لزلازل كبيره بلغت درجتها نحو سبع
درجات يتوقع الخبراء تكرار الزلازل في
مناطق اخرى لانها تقع ضمن حزام زلزلي على
غرار تركيا ويطالبون بالاستفاده من تجارب
دول كاليابان ومن التكنولوجيا الحديثه في
بناء المباني وتصميم الطرق والمرافق
العامه لتناسب الطبيعه الجيولوجيه
[موسيقى]
نحاول ان نفهم اكثر من اربد في شمال
الاردن الدكتور مصدوق التاج استاذ
الجيولوجيا التركيبيه وعلم الزلازل في
الجامعه الهاشميه دكتور مرحبا بك
استنادا على التاريخ الزلزالي للمناطق
وانطلاقا من هذا التقرير الذي تابعناه هل
توقع الزلزال في منطقه ما ممكن
يسعد مسائكم ويسعد مساء مشاهدين الجزيره
بالنسبه لتوقع الزلازل
لم يتوصل العلم لهذه اللحظه بالتوقع
الصحيح للزلزال
او تاكيد مكان او لحظه حدوث زلزال هناك
نوعين من التوقع شيء خلنا نقول طويل الامد
وقصير الامد قصير الامد نحدد المكان
والزمان والقوه هذا صعب جدا لكن الطويل
الامد يمكن لعبتنا التاريخ الزلزال
للمنطقه يعني انه زلزال كل مثلا 10 او 20
سنه بيصير بامكان اتوقع والله صار مثلا
2020 زلزال القادم 2040,60 وهكذا طيب
دكتور ما تاثير الهزات الارتداديه التي
تحصل في المناطق التركيه والمناطق السوريه
التي تضررت حتى الان
الزلازل شيء طبيعي زلزال مثل زلزال تركيا
بقوه سبعه وثمانيه عشر هذا الزلزال كبير
او الزلزال عظيم جدا المنطقه اللي تكسرت
او تكسر حوالي 200 كيلو متر بعمق حوالي 25
كيلو متر بالتالي يعني هذا حدث عظيم جدا
الصفيحه العربيه لما اصطدمت بالصفيحه
صفيحه الاناضول يعني عندك كسر كبير
وبالتالي الصفيحه هاي حتاخد وقت كثير جدا
حتى يصير لها ريلاكسيشن حتى تستقر للوضع
الاصلي وتفرغ الطاقه او اشي بسموه لاستك
تتفرغ بشكل يعني وترجع الطبيعيه فهذا
حيكون في هناك جداء للارتداديه كبير جدا
قد تمتد لاشهر او يمكن لسنه
شده هذه حتكون يعني الى اربعه الى خمسه كل
ما تقدم الزمان لقدام كل ما قوه هذه
الزلازل خفت اكثر تراجعت ولكن هل ممكن
دكتور ان يضرب
اخر نفس المنطقه يكون بنفس القوه او اكثر
قوه مثلا
لا هذا غير وارد غير وارد بالعادل
كبير والزلازل الوارده بكون تكسير اخف
الطاقه الناتجه خف يعني معظم الطاقه
الكبير الكسر الكبير اللي حكينا مساحه
كبير جدا بعد هيك بصير ريلاكسيشن او
الريبان الهاستك ريباوند
للصفيحه اللي تكسرت فبتصير خلينا نقول حتى
تستقر بكون زلازل صغيره جدا اصغر من
الزلزال الرئيسي طيب دكتور الذين تابعوا
هذه التغطيه سواء على الجزيره او على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اصيبوا بالقلق
خاصه اولئك الذين يسكنون بمناطق تعرضت
لزلازل ما هي النصائح المباشره
لمن يتابعنا الان في حال تعرضه لزلزال او
هزه ارضيه قويه مثلا
اذا تعرض الزلزال واحد يحاول انه في حاله
الزلزال بده يتحادا قدر الامكان يعني كان
مثلا في بناء بده يكون على الروح على
المكان
الاكثره يعني مش ضعيف مثلا في زاويه مثلا
غرفه في زاويه بناء يحتفل الاماكن
الذين يتركون البيوت ويذهبون الى الشوارع
دكتور هل هذا جيد
اذا لحق تمكن انه يفتح عن العماره اذا كان
مثلا عماره بعد عنها راح على الشارع او
منطقه خالي بكون افضل اذا قدر يتصرف يعني
خلال الزلزال كله خلال ثواني او عشر ثواني
عشرين ثانيه اذا كان عنده القدره انه يبعد
عن الماء للاماكن يبعد عن الخطوط الكهرباء
يبعد عن اي خطر فهذا شيء ممتاز جدا سريعا
كان ما قدرت سريعا الذين بالسيارات دكتور
سريعا لو سمحت
كله حيصير في الكثير عشر عشرين ثانيه مده
الزلزال اذا قدرت يبعد عن الاماكن اللي
فيها تهدمات بنايات خطوط كهرباء مناطق
خاليه تكون بعيده عن اي شيء فهذا جيد شكرا
لك الدكتور مصدوق التاج استاذ الجيولوجيا
التركيبيه وعلم الزلازل في الجامعه
الهاشميه في الاردن شكرا لك
الى جانب التداعيات الانسانيه الماسويه
للزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا بدات ارتدادته
المباشره تشمل بعض القطاعات الاقتصاديه في
البلاد وقد تراجع مؤشر بورصه اسطنبول في
تداولات اليوم باكثر من 8% الامر الذي دفع
الهيئات التنظيميه الى تعليق التداول
للمره الثانيه خلال يومين التقرير التالي
يستعرض تلك الارتدادات التي اعقبت الزلزال
العنيف اترككم مع بعض قليل نعود اليكم اذا
لمتابعه هذه التغطيه على راس الساعه
شهيده تركيا اسوا زلزال يعصف بها على مدى
قرن من الزمان فما هي التداعيات
الاقتصاديه التي عصفت بالاقتصاد التركي
جراء هذا الزلزال كشفت وكاله انباء
الاناضول التركيه ان هذا الزلزال اثر بشكل
كبير على الاوضاع الاقتصاديه لنحو 13
مليون ونصف مليون شخص في عشر ولايات تركيه
وافادت اداره الطوارئ التركيه ان الزلزال
دمر نحو
5775 مبنى هذا وتراجعت الليره التركيه عقب
الزلزال الى مستوى منخفض جديد امام
الدولار قبل ان تستعيد عافيتها وذكرت
وكاله
الخاصه ان مطار اضنه بجنوب تركيا اغلق
امام الرحلات الجويه حتى اشعار اخر كما
توقف تدفق النفط الخام عبر خط الانابيب
الواصل الى ميناء جيهان على البحر المتوسط
قبل ان يستانف نشاطه مجددا وقالت شركه
بوتاش التركيه لتشغيل خطوط الانابيب بان
تدفقات الغاز الطبيعيه توقفت الى مناطق
غاز عنتاب وهاتاي وقهرما المرش وبع
المناطق الاخرى نتيجه الاضرار التي لحقت
بخط نقل الغاز وكشفت هيئه الملاحه البحريه
التركيه ان ميناء اسكندرون الواقع على
البحر الابيض المتوسط بجنوب البلاد تضرر
جراء هذا الزلزال القوي وعلى اثر الزلزال
قامت بورصه اسطنبول باتخاذ اجراءات فاوقفت
التداول على اسهم ثمان شركات كما توقف
الانتاج على نحو واسع في مدينه غازي عنتاب
وذلك تخوفا من حدوث هزات ارتداديه خلال
الساعه القادمه ياتي ذلك فيما توقعت هيئه
المسح الجيولوجي الامريكيه ان الخسائر
الاقتصاديه جراء زلزال ستتعدى مليار دولار
تغطتنا مستمره اليكم تذكيرا بالعناوين
عدد قتل الزلزال في تركيا يقترب من سته
الاف وعدد الجرح يتجاوز 30 الفا
انقر تقول ان الزلزال ضرب مساحه تبلغ 110
كيلومترات اردوغان يعلن حاله طوارئ في عشر
محافظات تركيه تضررت بزلزال هو الاشد منذ
قرابه ربع قرن وتوقف امدادات الغاز
لمحافظات تركيه عده بعد تضرر خطوط
الانابيب
عدد قتل الزلزال في عموم سوريا يتجاوز
2000 وسقوط الاف الجرحى تضرر المعبر
المستخدم لنقد المساعدات الى شمال غرب
سوريا ومخاوف بشان مصير العالقين تحت
الانقاض
[تصفيق]
ب غداه زلزال المدمر سباق مع الزمن والبرد
لانقاذ الناجين المحتملين في تركيا وسوريا
بدا وصول المساعدات الدوليه وفرق المسعفين
الى تركيا وانقر تقول ان اكثر من 70 دوله
عرضت المساعده
وسط تحضيرات من توقع الاسوا الصحه
العالميه تقول ان عدد المتضررين بالزلزال
في تركيا وسوريا قد يصل الى 23 مليونا
وتتعهد بارسال امدادات طارئه والمتحدث
باسم الامين العامل للامم المتحده يقول
للجزيره ان المعابر بين جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا تواجه صعوبات تعيق ايصال المساعدات
اذا نعود للتذكير باخر التطورات حيث اعلن
وزير الصحه التركي فخر الدين قوجا ارتفاع
حصيله ضحايا الزلزال الى ما يزيد عن
5400 وفاه في حين بلغ عدد المصابين نحو 32
الفا ولفت وزير الصحه التركيه لان عدد من
تم انقاذهم من تحت الانقاض في ولايه هاتاي
حتى الان بلغ الفا 1800 شخص مشيرا الى
انهيار الفين وسبعمائه وتسعه واربعين مبنا
في ولايه هاتاي وحدها في حصيله اوليه كما
اعلن ان ما يقرب من عشره الاف شخص باتوا
في الخدمه على ارض الميدان ثلثهم من افراد
البحث والانقاذ
مع تكشف حجم الكارثه التي ضربت تركيا
وسوريا تعالت اصوات المنظمات الانسانيه
المحليه والدوليه في الشمال السوري محذره
من نقص الامكانيات وشح الاليات اللازمه
لعمليات الانقاذ في ظل تعثر وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه بما فيها الادويه في
مناطق منكوبه اصلا تقرير ماجد عبد الهادي
موت بالزلازل المدمره يتلو موتا بالعواصف
الثلجيه بعد موت بالاسلحه الفتاكه
والسوريون كالمعتاد في صداره قوافل
الضحايا يستغيثون دون كبير امل بامكانيه
نجدتهم او تخليصهم من هذه السلسله الرهيبه
في عالم طالما التهمه بانه تصرف على مدى
اثنتي عشره سنه داميه كانه اعتاد رؤيتهم
يذبحون
هم قالوا في وقت مبكر من العقد الماضي
قولتهم الجماعيه الشهيره ملنا غيرك يا
الله كنايه عن يقينهم بان حسابات المصالح
على المستوى الدولي كما الاقليمي اقتضت
تركهم لمصيرهم دونما اي محاولات جاده
لانقاذهم وما كان احد يتوقع حينئذ ان
تكتمل اشاحه البشريه بصرها عن نكبتهم
بوقوع كوارث طبيعيه وجيولوجيه تقتل الوفا
الناجين الذين لهم ان استطاعوا الفرار من
كوارث اسوا كانت اسفرت عن مقتل مئات
الالوف منهم صحيح انهم الان ليسوا وحدهم
وان ملايين الاتراك معهم في مهب العاصفه
زلداديه الجديده لكن الساعات الطويله
القاسيه التي مرت منذ زلزله الارض زلزالها
على جانبي الحدود بين البلدين المنكوبين
ظلت وما زالت تؤكد تباعا على كون هؤلاء لا
سيما اللاجئين والنازحين من بينهم هم
الاضعف قدره والاقل حيل في محاولاتهم
اليائسه لانتشال ذويهم احياء او موتى من
تحت انقاض المباني المدمره
لقد اطلقت تركيا وهي الدوله الاقليميه
الكبرى ذات القدرات الماديه والتقنيه
والاقتصاديه الضخمه انذارا من الدرجه
الرابعه في معيار الكوارث ما يعني حكما
طلب المساعدات الخارجيه التي بدات بالتدفق
فعلا من كل انحاء العالم وذكر مؤشر يكفي
لادراك فداحه الخطر الذي ينطوي عليه شحو
الامكانات في شمال سوريا حيث ملايين
النازحين والسكان الفقراء المتروكين
لاقدارهم دونما رعايه من اي سلطه بل الذين
لا تصلوا اليهم لقمه الخبز ان وصلت بغير
صفقات امميه معقده تبرمها الدول الكبرى في
الامم المتحده كل سته شهور وتتحدد بموجبها
المساعدات الغذائيه المسموح بتوريدها
لمناطقهم ومن اي المعابر تمر وكيف
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
يقال ان نوع وحجم الماساه يقتضيان النقي
عن تسييسها ويستدعيان حصر الاهتمام
بجانبها الانساني قيل ايضا ان هذا وقت
التمعن في الكارثه او التامل في ذواتنا
بدلا من التنقيب في خلفيات الحدث او
ابعاده وتلك اقوال ربما تخفف او تعزز وقع
الالم في نفوس من يراقبون المشهد على
شاشات التلفزه كل حسب وجهات نظره غير انها
لن تغير الكثير في مشاعر ام تبحث بين
الركام عن ابنها وهي تدرك ان الاليات
والمعدات اللازمه لانقاضه او انتشال جثته
قد تعذر وصولها لاسباب سياسيه او نتيجه
عوامل ترتبط بجشع صناع الماسي وشروطهم بان
يكونوا هم الاوصياء على المعونات المرسله
الى الضحايا
بتاسيس الكلام عن الزلزال اذا او من دونه
يمر الوقت الذي ربما كان من دم وصار اليوم
من هواء او من اوكسجين تبتعد لحظه وقوع
الزلزله في الزمن فتضيق مع ابتعادها انفاس
الاحياء المطبورين تحت الركام او تتحلل
جثث الميتين منهم لتتحلل في اللحظات نفسها
ايضا ارواح الواقفين فوق الركام وان ظلت
السونهم تلهج بالنشيد القديم مالنا غيرك
يا الله
نعود الى مراسلنا من داخل سوريا تحديدا في
اعزاز ريف حلب محمد الجزائري ومن مقر
الوان المتحده في نيويورك مراد هاشم محمد
ابدا معك واضح في الخلفيه تجمع للمنكوبين
هل دخلت اي مساعدات من خارج سوريا محمد
حتى الساعه
نعم في الحقيقه لا مساعدات دخلت من خارج
سوريا انما هذه المساعدات التي نشاهدها
خلفي ويقوم بتوزيعها متطوعون يوزعونها
للعائلات المنكوبه التي لجات الى هذه
الخيام قيام الايواء المؤقت التي انشات في
مدينه اعزاز يقيم اقامها المتطوعون الذي
يوزع هنا نشاهد هي عدد من الاغطيه
والبطانيات التي جمعها تم جمعها من الحي
كتبرعات من الاهالي ومن لديه فائض من
الاغطيه يقوم باعطائها الى هؤلاء
المتطوعون ليتم توزيعها الى الاهالي
المنكوبين الناجين من
الزلزال هؤلاء الاهالي الذين جاؤوا من
مدينه جنديرس والاتارب وعدد من المدن
المتضرره في محيط المنطقه مدينه اعزاز
وحدها مستقبلت حوالي 400 عائله في هذه
المراكز ايواء المؤقته هذه الخيمتان حقيقه
هذه القيمتان هما ض حوالي 150 عائله
النساء والاطفال يقيمون داخل هذه الخيام
انما الشباب والرجال والشيوخ يقيموا
يجلسون خارج هذه الخيمه يحرقونهم يحرق بعض
الاطارات وبعض الاغصان لتدفئه انفسهم
بالاضافه الى هذه الاغذيه حقيقه المشهد
مخيف جدا في هذه المناطق المتضرره
وبالتحديد مدينه جنديرس التي شهدت الضرر
الاكبر والنكبه الاكبر في هذه المنطقه حسب
احصائيات المجلس المحلي هناك 200 220 منزل
او بناء طابقي دمر بالكامل 70% من المدينه
مدمر بشكل جزئي اضافه الى ان هناك هذه
المدينه التي يقطنها حوالي 40 الف عائله
هذه العائلات شردت في مراكب في نقاط
اللواء المعقد ان بينما بعضهم تحت الانقاض
الاحصائيات الاوليه من هذه من مجلس المحلي
وفرق الان ان هناك ما يقارب مئتين شخص حتى
الان عالقين تحت الانقاض يقوم فرق الدفاع
الدفاع الدفاع المدني والفرق الاهليه
والمعارضه والعناصر من المعارضه المسلحه
بكل ما يمكن او كل ما يتوفر لديهم من
اليات للعمل على اجلاء هؤلاء الاهالي
والبحث عنهم وانقاذهم من تحت انقاذ ولكن
نحن هذه الفرق حقيقه تسابق الزمن تسابق
الزمن للوصول من اليمن هو ما زال حيا تحت
هذه الانقاض حتى الان هذه هذه الاوضاع
الانسانيه جدا صعبه المساعدات التي
الدوليه لم تدخل الى الاراضي السوريه
محمد تبرعات من المنظمات الانسانيه
والمنظمات المحليه والاهالي عن هذه
المساعده الدوليه وقبل ان اتحول بالسؤال
الى مراد هاشم في مقر الامم المتحده باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ستيفان تجاري
صرح للجزيره بان التحدي الاكبر حاليا امام
مجهود ايصال المساعدات للمنكوبين في
الشمال السوريه تمثل في تضرر الطرق
والمعابر هناك من الزلزال تشارك اضاف في
مقابلته على الجزيره ان سوء الاحوال
الجويه اضاف مزيدا من الصعوبه على فرق
الاغاثه في مناطق الزلزال
هذا مجرد بدايه لبدء
التشغيلي ماكينه المساعدات
وسوف نصدر نداء عاجلا سريعا
وساقود منها الان سنحتاج الى الملايين
والملايين من الدولارات في القريب العاجل
لمساعدته هؤلاء النازحين واللاجئين نتيجه
لهذه الكارت
اكد ان الامم المتحده بصدد اطلاق نداء
عاجل لجمع مزيد من الاموال لجهود الاغاثه
في تركيا وسوريا مشيرا الى ان مبلغ الخمسه
والعشرين مليون دولار الذي اعلن عنهما
الاعلن عنه صندوق الامم المتحده للطوارئ
سيكون باكوره المساعدات الامميه المخصصه
لمنكوبي السلسال
انهم في غايه الصعوبه ليس فقط لانك تتعامل
مع زلزال بل زلزال في ظروف شتاء قارس
بامكانكم ان تتخيلوا صعوبه الموقف كان
لدينا مساعدات موجوده من قبل في شمال غرب
سوريا نقوم بتوزيعها ونحن بحاجه الى ايصال
المزيد من المساعدات لكن التحدي يبقى
ماثرا لان المعابر الحدوديه بين الجنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا فيه صعوبات لان
الطرق المؤديه اليه
عانت من ضرر
اذا مراد انطلاقا من كلام دجاريك للجزيره
ما هي استراتيجيه الوان متحده
لارسال المساعدات وبدء عمليه الانقاذ
والاغاثه لمنكوبي الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا
نعم جلال اولا الانتهاء من عمليه التقييم
الجاريه بالتزامن مع استمرار
توزيع وايصال المساعدات ولا سيما في
الجانب السوري ان في المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها المعارضه او تلك التي يسيطر عليها
النظام من خلال ما هو متواجد ومتوفر من
مخزونات من هذه المساعدات في هذه المناطق
ايضا
جرى طلب
المساعدات متوفره في مخازن المنظمه وكالات
المنظمه في العديد من الدول الجوار وذلك
بانتظار توفر الاموال
الكافيه بعد اطلاق النداء الانساني
بطبيعه الحال توفير المزيد من هذه
المساعدات هناك توقعات بان تكون هناك
احتياجات انسانيه ضخمه ولا سيما في سوريا
بطبيعه الحال ستواجه الامم المتحده الى
جانب مساله توفير التمويل وان كانت هناك
مؤشرات يبدي تبدي الامم المتحده ارتياح
بشانها ومن ضمنها هذا التجارب الدولي فيما
يتعلق بتقديم المساعده
لتركيا من قرابه سبعين دوله حتى الان
الامم المتحده تناشد المجتمع الدولي
بطبيعه الحال ان يسهم ماليا لمواجهه
التبعات الناجمه عن هذه الكارثه هناك
توقعات بان تكون هناك احتياجات ضخمه
وبالتالي ستنشا تحديات مثل كيفيه وصول هذه
المساعدات بعد توفيرها بشكل سريع وبالحجم
المطلوب
هناك قلق بطبيعه الحال من ان الاليات
الحاليه قد لا تكون قد لا تسمح بهذه
الوتيره من ايصال المساعدات بكميات كبيره
وفي ان هناك
يتحدث الان
ويقول بان عدد قتل الزلزال ارتفع الى خمسه
الاف
وتسعين متابع مباشره هذه الكلمه لنائب
الرئيس التركي
ساذكر لكم التفاصيل ايضا
نوصل المروحيه والمركبه هذه الى الساحه
بشكل
سريع بخصوص المستشفيات كنت ذكرت لكم
البيانات لا يوجد هناك امر فارق
الاماكن التي تم تاسيس مستشفيات ميدانيه
فيها
تم تاسيس مستشفى ميداني جزئي فيها
هنالك
هذه المستشفيات تقدم خدماتها هذه متواجده
في مرش
وهطايا
نقيم المرحله وتطورات بشان هذا كله اما
بشان الايواء
وزير التربيه والتعليم كان افاد وافدت
بشان
الوضع في الجامعات والايواء في الجامعات
وما جاوز 31 ووحده تصلح للسكن
وزاره الشباب
150 الف سريع ليصبح المجموع ما يقارب 451
الف سرير طبعا هنا خارج مناطق الكوارث هذه
ايضا ما يقارب مليون ومئه
نطاق للمبيت السريك
في المحافظات ابتداء من اليوم
كما هو سيعلن في موقعي اداره
افدون من المحافظات
المنكوب الى هذه المحافظات
سيتم التفقد ما اذا كانوا اتوا من محافظتك
ومن ثم سيتم تذليل السبل لايوائهم
واذا طلب اخلاءهم اذا لم يتمكنوا من
الذهاب بانفسهم فسيتم ايضا نشر المعلومات
والاعلان عن نقاط التجمع ونقاط الاخلاء
من جانب الغذاء ايضا
بخصوصا اذكر النقطه هذه ايضا
بخصوص شان الايواء
المخيمات يتم تاسيسها في مناطق الكوارث
ويتم توزيعها بشكل فردي وايضا يتم انشاءه
المخيمات بشكل متكامل ايضا
ركزنا على هذا وايضا توزيع الخيم
والبطانيات
لاسيما ومع بروده الجو البطانيات
التي تم توزيعها والتي على وشك التوزيع
ما يقارب 900 الف بطانيه ما يقاربه مليون
بطانيه تم توزيعها وهي على وشك توزيع وهذا
رقم سنصل به الى مليون ونصف ومليانه
ومليونين قريبا جدا
[موسيقى]
الخيمه التي وصلت الى الميدان بالفعل
والتي هي على وشك التوزيع وصل عددها الى
مئه
خيمه شامله الخيام التي هي على وشك
التوزيع
كنا ذكرنا كانت هناك مناطق مغلقه
خارج اماكن الكوارث كما هي في منطقه قونيا
وقيصري
هنالك
مناطق كانت مغلقه الطرق اغلقت في بعض
المناطق وايضا في نور ضل بسبب كارثه
الزلزال كانت السيب هناك كانت حركه هناك
مغلقه هذا اثر على التحركنا طبعا بشكل
كبير لكن اليوم هذه المنطقه تم فتح السير
فيها
على مسرب واحد اولا ومن ثم تم فتح كل
المساجد وهذا طبعا
التحركات على القطاع البري وسهل
اعمال الايواء
وايضا بشان المخيمات
كما تعلمون
مخيمات المساكن المتنقله لتقييم هذه
المراحل
نواصل اعمالنا وبدانا باعمال السكنات
المتنقله بخصوص الغذاء ذكرت انهما يقارب
451 الف شخص
سيتم توفيق الغذاء لهم الى جانب السكن طعم
بالاضافه الى ذلك وزاره التربيه والتعليم
ايضا هناك تقوم بجهد جبار وكذلك اجيال
الاحمر وكذلك منظمات المجتمع المدني هنا
اذكر لكم بعض الامثلات من باب المثال لا
الحصر من بعض انجازات الوزارات
400 الف رغيف خبز تم توقيعه توزيعه في
اربع محافظات واربعمائه وثلاث الاف
قوارير مياه 128 مطبخ متنقل في المحافظات
العشر هذه فقط انجازات وزاره التربيه
والتعليم ايضا في البستان
وفي اصلاحيه في هذه المدن ايضا
بخصوص الغذاء
الى جانب انشطه اضافيه هناك اعمال قائمه
في هذه المدن ايضا في ايضا
ودعم اضافي يتم في هذه المدن
وبالنسبه
للتعليم
هنالك جهد الجبار
فرص وامكانات وزاره التربيه والتعليم
لخدمه الشعب انا هنا اشكر الوزارات مره
اخرى وزاره التربيه والتعليم اشكركها ايضا
الهلال الاحمر ايضا لانه ايضا يقوم بتراس
لجنه العمل هناك يقوم بجهد كبير على
انقطاعي توفيق المياه وتوفيق الغذائي ايضا
وايضا على مجال تاسيسي افران الخبز في
المحافظات وفي المدن التابعه للمحافظات
هنالك جهد كبير تبذله
يبذله الهلال الاحمر
وابتداء من الغد ان شاء الله سنشهد
نهايه للمشاكل المتعلقه بالغذاء والخبز
ابتداء من الغد وبالنسبه للطاقه
المولدات ما يزيد على 30 مولدا
كان كنا قد اخذناها في قطاع الصيانه بقي
من كان قد بقي منها سته امس
وكنت ذكرت ان اثنين سيتم تعمييرها يوم امس
تم تعميق ثلاثه من هذه المولدات الرئيسيه
نحن الان في وضع نوافرك فيه الكهرباء بشكل
اسهل
وابتداء من الغد سيتم توفيق كهرباء الى
القطاعات التي هي المناطق التي لم يتم
توفيق كهرباء التي لا يتم توفيق كهرباء
فيها لكن
بتدوج
بحسب الظروف طبعا في مناطق
القاضي لان لا يتسبب هذا في كوارث اخرى
نحن نولي هذا الامر حساسيه كبيره ان لا
يتفاقم تتفاقم الكارثه بخصوص الاتصال ايضا
نوفق التسهيلات بشان الاتصال لان هذا
مرتبط بشكل وثيق بالكهرباء كما تعلمون
بالنسبه للاتصال
بخصوص استخدامي شبكات الاتصال محطات
الاتصال
وايصال الطاقه اليها وايضا بخصوص المناطق
المتاثره بالمحطات الكهربائيه الرئيسيه
الثلاث
هنا ايضا
لم نتمكن من ايصال الكهرباء اليها بسبب
عطل في بسبب انقطاع الشبكه الان ما يقارب
مولد كهربائي فرع تم توصيله والمتبقي سيتم
سيكون قد وصل بالكامل هذه الليله وبالتالي
نكون قد حلينا مشكله الاتصال والكهرباء
وبخصوص الغاز الطبيعي الخطوط الرئيسيه
للغاز الطبيعي في سته مناطق مختلفه كان
هناك انكسارات
جسيمه اضرار جسيمه
وايضا بالتزامن مع الهزات الاكسداديه التي
تواصلت هذه الخطوط ارتفع عددها الى تسعه
لكن هذا لم يؤثر على اعمالنا ولن يؤثر
ان شاء الله ابتداء من الغد
اذا لم نواجه مفاجات جديده
نسال الله ان نواجهها زلزال جيدا ابتداء
من الغد ان شاء الله سنكون نخطط لانهائي
الاعمال في هذه الخطوط واعاده ايصال
الغازي بشكل تدرججي بما لا يفتح الباب الى
كوارثه جديده تنتج عن ايصال الغاز الطبيعي
الى مناطق دون تفقد
لظروف
بما يحول دون تفاقم الكارثه
وان شاء الله ابتداء من الغد نكون قد
اوصلنا الغاز طبيعي الى كامل المنطقه
وبالنسبه للوقود السائل
والبقيه ستصل خلال الليل ان شاء الله
ايضا
الخزانات المتنقله
650 خزان وقود متنقل يصل المنطقه وطبعا
هذا يسهل توزيع الوقود بشكل افضل يذهب الى
مناطق التوزيع دون ان تحتاج السيارات الى
ان تاتي الى محطه الوقود وبالتالي نكون قد
لا نواجه مشكله بالنسبه
الوقود
هذا الوضع العام بالنسبه لوضع الغاز
الطبيعي والكهرباء والطاقه نحن في الحقيقه
حققنا تطورات مهمه اذا نظرنا الى
المحافظات العشر هناك اربع محافظات نحن
وصلنا فيها الى وضع نريح على راس هذه
المحافظات كيلس
هذه المحافظات بالنسبه للمحافظات الاخرى
العمل هنا بات اسهل بكثير حققنا تطورات
مهمه والمحافظات الست المتبقيه نركز
جهودنا ونكثفها فيها وهذا طبعا يسهل
الاعمال بالنسبه للغذاء هنالك ملاحظات
امامي طبعا كنت شاركتها واياكم
بالنسبه للمواصلات لدي بشاره لكم بشاره
تسهل كافه الاعمال الاخرى كما هو في
الطاقه وهذه بشاره هي انه تقريبا
لم يبقى لدينا طريق مغلق
يحول دون تحقيق دعم لوجستي الى مناطق
الكوارث ليس لدينا اي طريق مغلق يحول دون
ايصال الدعم اللوجستي الى مناطق الكوارث
طبعا هذا اشاركه واياكم واشاركه مع الراي
العام ايضا
المناطق الصناعيه
هذا ملف ايضا تاثره في الكارثه
ماذا تاثره وهل تاثر هذا احد اكثر الاسئله
التي يتم توجيها الينا اليوم
سالت السيد الوزير ان يقوم بتوضيح حول هذا
الامر اذا قام بتوضيح موجز حول هذا شاكرا
له
اشكركم السيد نائب رئيس الجمهوريه
وانا بدوري
اتمنى مساء سعيدا لاصدقائي هنا لدينا
ضحايا مفقودون توفوا رحمهم الله جميعا
واسال الله الشفاء العاجل
للجرحى
كما تفضل السيد نائب رئيس الجمهوريه
المناطق التي تاثرت من الكارثه تاثرت على
قطاع الصناعي ايضا هذه المناطق هي احدى
اهم مراكز الصناعه في تركيا واعتبارا من
اليوم الاول
اصدقائنا في الوزاره وايضا العاملون في
الوزارات الاخرى
تابعنا الملف وتابعنا الكارثه عن كثب
وكنا على اتصال دائم ومتواصل مع العاملين
في قطاع الصناعه نحاول اداره هذه المرحله
بافضل شكل ممكن
بنسبه المدن
الصناعيه وايضا المصانع التي هي خارج
المدن الصناعيه والمناطق الصناعيه
لا يوجد اي هدم
ايها انهدام
يضر بمرحله الانتاج طبعا هذا خبر مفرح لنا
الان
في بعض المدن بسبب عدم وصول الغاز الطبيعي
المؤسسات والمصانع تواصل انتاجها باستثناء
التي تعتمد على الغاز الطبيعي طبعا وكما
ينوه دائما السيد الرئيس الجمهوريه
الاستثمار والانتاج
والاستخدام اي فرص العمل
والتوريد هذه المراحل الاربعه مهم جدا
وفورما نتجاوز هذه المرحله مرحله هذه
سنستمر وسنواصل هذه القطاعات الاربع طبعا
هنا نؤكد على امر وهو انه اعتبارا من
اليوم الاول
فالمصنعون والصناعيون
تكاتفوا معنا
وتحملوا جزءا من هذا الحمل الثقيل بعد
الكارثه
ونحن
بالتالي
لقينا منهم استجابه ممتازه وبالتالي نحن
نشكرهم بسبب هذا الدعم الكبير الذي
وفروه وحققوه لتركيا انا اشكر
صناعيين في تركيا باسم الحكومه وباسم
الوزراء الاخرين ايضا
اود ان اعطي مثالا واحدا فقط
لان السيد النائب رئيس الجمهوريه قال ذلك
فقط صناعي محافظه اوشك وحدهم خلال مكافحه
ادرار هذا الزلزال وليدعموا
مواطنين
ارسلوا
مليون بطانيه هم يرسلون بعض هذه البطانيات
مليون بطانيه بعضها وصلوا بعضها في الطريق
ليساعد المواطنين في مواجهه وطبعا هذا
يوضح لكم عن مدى ان شعبنا جسد واحد وعمده
تضامن شعبها طبعا الضحايا
ضحايا هذه الزلزال امر محزن جدا نسال الله
رحمه لهم مره اخرى لكن ملف الانتاج
تركيا
سنواصل دعم تركيا لتكون بلدا منتجا قويا
سنواصل دعمنا كحكومه في هذا الاطار
واسال الله ان يستمر هذا الامر على هذا
النسق ايضا مره اخرى اشكر
الاعلاميين واسال الله الرحمه لمواطنين
اتمنى الشفاء العاجل للجرحى ايضا ان شاء
الله سنتجاوز هذه المرحله معا يدا بيد
وكتفا بكتف نتكاتف معا اشكركم السيد نائب
رئيس الجمهوريه
نعم وانا اشكركم ايضا
[موسيقى]
وان كانت من فرصه فاود ان اقدم فرصه
للساده الوزراء ليقدموا لنا موجزا حول
الاعمال المتعلقه بهذا القطاع
ولا سيما
بشان استقبال المساعداتي وتوزيعها
سيدنا ابراهيم الجمهوريه اشكركم جزيلا
الاعلاميون الراي العام
طاب مسائكم وانا بدوري بدايه اسال الله
الرحمه
للمتوفين في هذه الكارثه واسال الله
الشفاء العاجله للجرحى واسال الله السلامه
لشعبنا
كما تعلمون ضمن اطار اداره الازمه وزارتنا
لها مسؤوليه اساسيتان اولهما الدعم
الاجتماعي والنفسي
الدعم النفسي
وفي هذا الاطار فراقنا منذ اللحظه الاولى
كانوا في الساحه كانوا في الميادين
وايضا
وجهنا الموظفين العاملين في محافظات
المجاوره ايضا الى مناطق الكوارث وبداوا
اعمالهم في الساحه وكما ذكر نائب السيد
نائب رئيس الجمهوريه قبل قليل بالنسبه
للدعم العينين كانت هنالك مراكز الدعم
اللوجستيه التي تم تحديدها من قبل تحركنا
فيها ووفرنا المساعدات التي هي موجوده في
مخازن بالفعل وكذلك
المساعدات التي تم توفيرها من قبل
المنظمات منظمات المجتمع المدني
والمواطنين وفي هذا اطار كل الاحتياجات
احتياجات المواطنين
وبالنسبه تامين هذه الاحتياجات وتوفيرها
لمواطنين
عملنا بشكل منتظم
وبتنسيق كامل مع رئاسه اداره الكوارث
الطوارئ ونواصل اعمالنا في هذا هنا
اشارككم بعض النقاط
وهي انها المؤسسات التي توافق
سكنا لا سيما دور المسنين
وذوي الاعاقه
نحن بحمد الله لم تتلقى ايه
مؤسسه او مبنى تابع
لمؤسستنا ووزارتنا اي ضرر كبير
باستثناء بعض الاستثناءات بالنسبه للاطفال
ايضا ونقل الاطفال الى اماكن اكثر هناك
بعض الملفات والقضايا الان مواطنين الذين
يقيمون في الاماكن التي توفر خدمه السكن
التابعه لوزرتها لم يبقى لدينا اشكال فقط
بالنسبه للاطفال الذين لموافق لهم من
ضحايا الكوارث هنا ايضا اود ان اشارككم
هذا الاعلان هذه المعلومات الاطفال الذين
لا مرافق لهم نحن كوزاره
في منطقه الكوارث
اولئك الاطفال
نحن نتحمل مسؤوليتهم
ونستقبلهم وما سوى ذلك من الاطفال الذين
تم
استنقاذهم وتم
استكمل علاجهم في المستشفيات نستقبلهم
ايضا في
نستضيفهم في مؤسسات ودوائر وزارتنا وانبه
هنا
انه لم يتم تسليم اي شخص
لاي طفل لاشخاص مجهولين قبل التاكد من
الهويات
كل الاطفال يتم التاكد من هوياتهم ومن
هويات من يطلبون ان يسلم الاطفال اليهم في
هذه النقطه انبه الى هنا لان هناك مخاوف
عن بعض الناس وايضا للاسف ارى هناك انتشار
بعض المعلومات المغلوطه حول هذا الامر
وبالتالي
تبعنا هذا الايجاز لمجموعه من الوزراء
ونائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد اقطاي يشرحون
تطور مراحل الاغاثه للمناطق المنكوبه جراء
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا على كل حال
السيد حسين اوروج نائب المدير العام
لهيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه سيد حسين
طبعا تبعنا السيد فؤاد اقطاي نائب الرئيس
واشار الى ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا حتى الان
الى 5000 وثمانمائه
واربعه وتسعين ما هي العوامل التي تساهم
في ارتفاع عدد الضحايا الكبير في نحن
مقبلون على 48 ساعه من الزلزال المدمر في
تركيا
اولا اود ان اشكر الجزيره
لانها بطقت على الزلزال التركي على جندتها
وسمحت بالدعم لنا من كل انحاء العالم
الكارثه كبيره وانا اعمل في قطاع الاغاثه
الانسانيه منذ 30 عاما
وشاهدت الكثير من الكوارث في اجزاء مختلفه
من العالم هذه الكارثه هي الاكبر في
ثلاثين عاما
وليس في مكان وحد ضربت اكثر من عشر مدن
وكثير من المدن الصغيره والكبيره تضررت
بشكل مباشر وهناك حاجه
لتغطيه هذه المناطق كلها واحيانا ان نصل
الى المباني المنهاره متاخرين ولهذا السبب
القام الضحايا ترتفع وربما قد نرى من اكبر
حتى مما وصلنا اليه حتى الان
لماذا تصلون متاخرين هل بسبب نقص قله في
الامكانيات ام بسبب الانتشار الواسع
للدمار
في الحقيقه في تركيا
الدوله والحكومه
والمنظمات المدنيه تتهيا
للزلازل بشكل جيد هيئه الاغاثه الاسلاميه
فقط التي اعمل لديها لدينا عشرات الفرق
وعلى اكثر من الف شخص على الارض موجودين
حاليا لكن كما قلنا المناطق التي اصابها
الزلزال كبيره جدا ومتراميه
الطراف وقد بلغ عدد المباني المنهاره
حوالي عشره الاف فانت تحتاج على الاقل 100
شخص لكل مبنى منهار هذا يعني انت تحتاج
الى اكثر من 500 الف شخص بمعدات جيده
لتغطيه كل هذه المباني لهذا السبب نواجه
هذه الصعوبات وال يستغرق وقتا وفرق
الانقاذ وفرق الاغاثه تعمل بشكل جيد لكن
عدد المباني التي انهارت عدد كبير جدا
لهذا السبب
ان نحن نحتاج الى دعم دوله كبير في تركيا
والمناطق المجاوره وعلينا ان نزيد من عدد
فرق الانقاذ باسرع وقت ممكن
وعدد الفرق المتاحه لدينا ليس كافيا
ويجب على الفرق فرق الانقاذ ان تاتي من كل
مكان في العالم لمساعدتنا في جهودنا في
تركيا نحن نعلم بان فرق الانقاذ تسابق
الزمن والبرد ايضا لانقاذ من هم عالقين
تحت الانقاذ هل لديكم فكره تقريبيه عن عدد
المفقودين او العالقين تحت الانقاض حتى
الان في المناطق الاكثر تضررا مثلا في في
تركيا
للاسف لا نمتلك الارقام الدقيقه لكن ربما
سيكون اكثر مما نعرف حتى الان لان كل
الفرق النشطه على الارض واكثر من الف شخص
من العاملين في مجال الانقاذ من هيئه
الاغاثه الانسانيه التركيه
وعلى الدوام هم يرسلون الينا
مشاهداتهم وتقاريرهم وهناك الكثير من
المباني يعرفون ان هناك اشخاصا عالقين
فيها تحت الانقاض وهم يحاولون التواصل
الارقام ارقام العالقين كبيره للاسف لا
نستطيع حصرهم بدقه الان نسمع كثيرا بان
الارقام مرشحه ارقام الضحايا طبعا مرشحه
للارتفاع
ومنظمه الصحه العالميه تحذر من الارقام
ستكون اكثر بكثير من المعلنه الاوليه
حتى الان ما هو المطلوب حاليا او ماء او
ما هي الاولويه الان للحد من ارتفاع هذه
الارقام
نعم
مجموع النهائي
للسكان الذين تضرروا بشكل مباشر هو اكثر
من 13 مليون شخص وهو رقم هائل وعندما ننظر
الى بعض الصور في بعض المدن هناك دمار شبه
كامل
وبمجرد ما نستطيع علينا ان نزيد من اعداد
فرق الانقاذ والى جانب جهود لانقاذ علينا
ان ننبئ الاحتياجات الخاصه
لنتذكر ان البرد قارص واحيانا درجات
الحراره هي تحت الصفر وهناك معاناه شديده
ولا توجد اماكن كافيه
لوائهم وهناك الكثير من المباني تضررت
بعضها لم يتضرر لكن الناس خائفون من
العوده الى هذه
ويبقون خارجها وفي اقرب وقت ممكن علينا ان
نجري احصائياتنا ونصل الى هؤلاء ونزلوا
اليهم الاغطيه والبطانيات والملابس
سيد حسين الحراره
لهم الطعام ايضا شكرا لكم السيد حسين
اوروج نائب المدير العام لهيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه التركيه في اسطنبول
اداه ويستمر وصول المساعدات الاغاثيه الى
تركيا وسوريا من نحو 70 دوله في العالم
وفور وصولها بدات طلائع فرق الانقاذ عملها
في سباق مع الزمن املا في العثور على
ناجين تحت الانقاض
على تركيا وبشكل اقل سوريا تتدفق فرق
الاغاثه من مختلف انحاء العالم
تتعزز عمليات الانقاذ لكنها في اليوم
التالي للزلزال المدمر تواجه تحدي الوقت
والطقس في العثور على احياء تحت الركام
الهبه الدوليه لمساعده البلدين المنكوبين
ضمت عشرات البلدان على امتداد القارات
الخمس وبمشاركات متفاوته قوامها فرق انقاذ
واطقم طبيه ومعدات ومستشفيات ميدانيه
وغيرها من الامدادات الغذائيه والدوائيه
مؤازره للضحايا في هذه الفاجعه الانسانيه
الكبرى
وبينما يستمر اتباعا وصول فرق الانقاذ
والاسعاف بدات اولى طلائعها فورا عمليات
البحث والانقاذ لا سيما في المدن التركيه
المنكوبه وهي عمليات توشك على ان تدخل
مرحله حرجه فمع انقضاء كل ساعه بل كل
دقيقه تتضائل فرص العثور على ناجين لا
سيما من الاطفال الذين رجحت منظمه الامم
المتحده للطفوله يونيسيف ان يكون الاف
منهم قد قضوا في هذا الزلزال اما منظمه
الصحه العالميه فتوقعت ان يصل عدد
المتضررين من الزلزال الى 23 مليون شخص
والوضع اكثر سوءا في المناطق السوريه خاصه
تلك الخارج عن سلطه النظام شمالا اذ تواجه
جهود الاغاثه عقبات اشد تعقيدا تبدا
بالعوائق اللوجستيه ممثله بانعدام
والموانئ واغلاق معظم المعابر الحدوديه
باستثناء معبر باب الهوى المكتظ فضلا عن
الاعتبارات السياسيه والقانونيه التي تحول
دون التنسيق مع دمشقى الخاضعه لعقوبات
دوليه منذ سنوات
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
مرحبا بك سيد توماسو تركيا طبعا دوله
لديها امكانيات وتصلها مساعدات ولكن ما
تقييمكم للوضع الانساني في الشمال السوري
الذي لم تصله المساعدات حتى الان
مساءكم اولا
شكرا لاتاحه الفرصه لنا اولا اقول ان حجم
الدمار في كل من تركيا وسوريا كبير جدا
[موسيقى]
والحاجه الماسه لدعمهما موجوده فعلا ما
نراه الان ان في كل لحظه هناك مساعدات تصل
بالطبع الوضع في سوريا معقد للغايه تعلمون
تماما ان البلد عانى على مدى 12 عاما من
نزاع مسلح وظروف المعيشه
الحياتيه صعبه
للغايه احيانا في الكهرباء لا تتوفر الا
لمده ساعه في اليوم هناك مشكلات مع البنى
التحتيه والان حتى ازاله
والوصول الى الناس ما تامرا صعبا كل هذا
يفاقم من التحديات التي نواجهها لكن لدينا
متطوعين من الهلال الاحمر التركي والهلال
الاحمر السوري وهم يعملون على مدار الساعه
بحثا عن من بقي تحت الانقاض وهم عالقون
تحت الانقاذ بحثا عن ناجين طبعا حتى الان
هناك معبر واحد بين تركيا وشمال السوري هو
معبر باب الهوى وحتى هذا المعبر تضرر جراء
الزلزال بحسب ما افادت الامم المتحده
ما هي الخطه السريعه بتقديركم لايصال
المساعدات للمحتاجين في الشمال السوري
دقيق
مره اخرى نكرر ام مرت اقل من 48 ساعه على
الزلازل هذه فتقييم الموضع الموقف على
الارض ما زال مستمرا نحن ندرك ان الموقف
معقد وقد لن يستمر اليومين او اسبوعين بل
ربما اشهر ما نقوم به اولا هو ان نعمل من
خلال
الهلال الاحمر السوري لدعمهم على الارض
ولكي نضمن
الاستمرار في تقديم الدعم للناس على الارض
اضافه الى ذلك
قمنا باطلاق
مناشده بمجموع 12 مليون فرنك سويسري طبعا
هذه اموال سوف تساعد جهودنا في الاسابيع
والاشهر القليله المقبله
ابرز التحديات والمعوقات التي تتوقعون ان
تواجهونها كفرق انقاذ لا سيما في الصليب
الاحمر والدفاع المدني سواء كان في الداخل
السوري او في المناطق التركيه المنكوبه
التي كما تفضلت وقمت بانها تحتاج ربما الى
اشهر
للاغاثه ورفع الانقاض
الوضع كما قلنا
هناك
الحاجات التي ذراها تزداد في كل لحظه في
كل دقيقه فقط اضربه لكم مثلا بعد اقل من
24 ساعه ارسلنا اول فريق طوارئ يوم امس
وايضا
توقعنا ان عدد المتضررين سيزداد بحدود
المليون
وفي هذه المواقع هناك طبعا كارثه وطنيه
كبيره نحن اولا نخصص الصندوق طوارئ اموال
لحاله الطوارئ هذه وبعد ذلك سوف ندعم جهود
الدعم وانقاذ حياه الناس ايضا
ايطالي الطعام والماء وتوفير الملاجئ
فنقل الجرحى عندما تصل الاموال سوف نستمر
في دعمنا من حيث دعم
ربما بعض المساعدات النقديه لكي نعطيها
للناس ليقرروا هم كيف يستغلونها بطريقه
تحفظ كرامتهم افضل منا نسلمهم صناديق فيها
مساعدات عينيه مثلا وهذا ايضا سترافقه
نشاطات نشاطات اخرى
واعاده نقوم بها في مرحله ما بعد الهزات
شكرا لك
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر في
جنيف
اكثر من غيرها تهدد الهزات الارضيه
والزلازل مناطق في العالم ويعود ذلك اساسا
الى تركز النشاط الزلزالي في مناطق
جغرافيه تعرف بالاحزمه الزلزاليه بسبب ضيق
هذه الاحزمه تحدث الزلازل عاده بعد تحرك
الصفائح التكتونيه المكونه بل المكونه
للغلاف الصخري الخارجي في اتجاهات متعاكسه
ويشير جيولوجيون الى ثلاثه احزمه رئيسيه
نتعرف عليها في هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
تتكون الطبقه الخارجيه للارض المعروفه
باسم الغلاف الصخري من عدد من الصفائح
التكتونيه الكبيره او الحواف تتحرك لتكون
اما متباعده عن بعضها او مستضمه او منزلقه
عبر حدودها ما يجعل الزلازل مدمره وجود
تحركات عنيفه وقويه في الصفائح التكتونيه
وتتسبب هذه القوه في هزات ارضيه تبعتها
تختلف حسب اختلاف قوه التصادم ولان تركيا
تقع بين لوحين متصادمين هما لوح شمال
افريقيا ولوح منطقه اوراسيا فالزلازل تحدث
عاده عند تقابل هذين اللوحين وتحركيهما
ويسمى الاصطدام عمليه الاندساس على مر
الازمنه تشكلت احزمه زلزاليه ابرزها
واشهرها الحزم الناري ويمتد على طول 40
الف كيلو متر من التشيلي الى المكسيك
مرورا بالساحل الغربي للولايات المتحده
الى الاجزاء الجنوبيه من الاسكا ثم يمتد
ليشمل اليابان والفلبين غينيا الجديده
ونيوزيلندا يشبه حدوه حصان ويسمى حزم
النار لانه يضم اكثر من 450 بركانا ويحدث
فيه نحو 80% من زلازل الارض الاعنف في
العالم بينها زلزال تشيلي الكبير عام 60
من القرن الماضي الحزام الاخر هو الحزام
الالبي ويقع في منطقه تمتد لاكثر من 15
الف كيلو متر من
اندونيسيا نحو المحيط الاطلسي ويعبر جبال
الهيمالايا وجبال ايران والقوقاز
والاناضول والبحر الابيض المتوسط في هذا
الحزام تقع نحو 17% من اكبر الزلازل في
العالم وشهد اكثر الزلازل تدميرا مثل
زلزال باكستان عام 2005 وزلزال اندونيسيا
المدمر عام 2004
من ابرز الدول المهدده بزلازل في هذا
الحزام كل من تركيا والهند وكازاخستان
ودول جنوب اوروبا المطله على البحر الابيض
المتوسط ودول الشرق الاوسط مثل سوريا
ولبنان ودول شمال افريقيا ومصر الحزام
الثالث هو حزام منتصف الاطلسي ويمثل منطقه
التقاء الصفائح القاريه ويحدث في عمق
المحيط وبعيدا عن الاماكن الحضريه مسؤول
عن ثلاثه في المئه فقط من الزلازل الكبيره
اذ ان اغلبها صغيره لكن ايسلندا كمثال
تعرضت لزلازل كبيره بلغت درجتها نحو سبع
درجات يتوقع الخبراء تكرار الزلازل في
مناطق اخرى لانها تقع ضمن حزام زلزالي على
غرار تركيا ويطالبون بالاستفاده من تجارب
دول كاليابان ومن التكنولوجيا الحديثه في
بناء المباني وتصميم الطرق والمرافق
العامه لتناسب الطبيعه الجيولوجيه
[موسيقى]
من مدينه جبيل ينضم الينا السيد عطا الياس
الباحث المتخصص في الجيوفيزياء وعلم
الزلزال سيد الياس ما الذي جعل زلزال
تركيا مدمرا على نطاق الواسع
الفالق الفالق الذي حدث عليه الزلزال
ووفالق شرق الاناضول وفعلق ممتد على حوالي
100 كيلومترات
والطريقه التي يتصرف بها زلزاليا هو
لا
يحدث هزات ارضيه
بنفس الكميه طول الوقت ولكن
عنده هدوء نسبي زلزالي الى حين حدوث
طاقه كافيه
لكسر الفالق وتحريك الفالق خلال هزه قويه
وهذا ما شاهدناه منذ يومين
والطاقه التي تخرج منه بهذا الحاله تكون
طاقه قد تنيزت داخلهم لمده طويله هذا من
ناحيه من ناحيه ثانيه اكيد هناك العامل
الجغرافي ناحيه العمار ونوع الاعمار
الجيولوجيه التي يتم العمار عليها وحاله
الاعمار خاصه نحن نشهد منطقه تعرضت لحرب
وكان فيها استخدام
للقنابل والمدافع وهي مما يضادع قوه
المبنى من الناحيه السوريه
اكيد الحاله ليست كذلك هل صحيح باننا
نشهد تكرار للزلازل في هذه المنطقه بشكل
متواتر اكثر من
السنوات السابقه او العقود السابقه
في هذه المنطقه اردتم بالقول منطقه الشرق
الاناضول صحيح منطقه المشرق منطقه شرق
الاردن نعم
شرق الاناضول نعم كما ذكرنا فالق شرق
الاناضول لا يحدث بنفس الوتيره لقد كان في
العقود الماضيه كان يتسم بنسبه زلزاليه
خفيفه الى ان حدث هذا الزلزال
اما المنطقه بالاجمال فهي ايضا فيها
العديد من الفوالق وهذه الفوالق ايضا
قد احدث زلازل قويه في التاريخ الى ان
التاريخ الحديث
ليس فيه اي اثر لزلزال بهذه القوه او
بزلزال قوي
هذا هذا اعتيادي لعمل الزلازل كما قلنا ان
زلازل تتكرر بقوه ما على على فالق ومن
المعروف ان تفالق الشرق الاناضول يتصرف
هكذا ودوران الزلازل او تردد الزلازل عليه
تاخذ ما بين المئه عاما الى حوالي 300
350 عاما هذه نتائج الابحاث التي اجريت
منذ فترات طويله على على هذا اذا بالنسبه
لي كاختصاصي بالزلازل هذا التصرف هذا
الفعل قد تصل بهذا التصرف الزلزالي وقد
اثبته البارحه للاسف طيب
سيد عطا قبل دقائق المركز الاولى متوسط
لرصد الزلازل اشار الى هزه ارضيه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بقوه
4.4 درجات على مقياس ريختر هذه تعتبر هزه
ارتداديه جراء زلزال تركيا
ابدا ابدا هذه هزه مثل عده هزات اكثر من
عده مئات من الاجزاء تحصل في هذه المنطقه
سنويا
واكثر من عده مئات
فهذه هزه طبيعيه ليس لها اي تاثير او اي
علاقه بهزه تركيا وسوريا لماذا لان فوالق
ليست متصله ببعضها في هذه المنطقه ان
الفالق الذي حدث عليه الزلزال الكبير في
سوريا في شمال سوريا
ومختلف وموجود على صفيحه مختلفه عن الفارق
التي عن الزلزال الذي تحرك وحصل منذ حوالي
نصف ساعه في منطقه نابلس بدفع الغربيه
شكرا لك السيد عطاء الياس الباحث المتخصص
في العلوم الجيوفيزيائيه والزلازل كنت
معنا من جبيل في لبنان لتشرح لنا عن واقع
الزلازل في المنطقه تحديدا بعد زلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا واراضي في شمال